ازمه سياسيه ودمار ومشاهد حرب استفاق
عليها السودانيون والعانه
طرفان عسكريان يتنازعان فلماذا يحدث كل
ذلك هذه الشبكات بين قوتين عسكريتين القوه
الاولى بقياده عبد الفتاح البرهان والقوه
الثانيه اسمها دعم السريع بقياده دخل
المعروف بحميتي القوتان ساهمت خلال
السنوات الماضيه في انهاء حكم البشير
وسندتا الحراك الشعبي وكان من المفترض دمج
القوتين العسكريتين في قوه واحده لتسهيل
الانتقال السياسي في البلاد لكن ضم
القوتين انتهى بالفشل قوه الدعم السريع
انتشرت في اماكن مهمه في الخرطوم وتوقت
مطار مروي سرعان ما استنفرت القوات
المسلحه وبدات اتهامات المتبادله تحولت
الى توتر ثم صارت توتر اشتباكاتا مسلحه
وقصفا متبادلا وسيطره بقوه السلاح على
اماكن حساسه في الدوله وصدم مخاوف من تطور
الاوضاع الى حرب اهليه تضرب السودان
[موسيقى]